let me tell you one thing that once i  understood this made a big difference  for my life and this is that failure has  no meaning so many people beat  themselves up they did something wrong  something didn't go as planned oh this  must be because i'm not good enough  because i'm not smart enough because i  am a failure this is why these things  didn't work out the truth is this isn't  correct failure has no inherent meaning  failure out of itself means nothing it  only means the things that you attach to  it the lots of highly successful people  that failed plenty of times so sure  thing if you fail somewhere learn from  it what went wrong but then just move on  follow for more career advice